[Music]
hi
my name is barrett schlerke and i'm a
software engineer on the shiny team at
rstudio
today we're going to talk about how
plumber and future
can be combined to create an
asynchronous web api
so let's consider an example where we
have two r functions
each function takes an id but the first
one we'll do a fast calculation
we can think it'll take roughly zero
seconds and the second one
will do a slow calculation this one will
take about 10 seconds
plumber can take these two functions and
decorate them
using oxygen 2 like comments in this
case
both of these functions can be accessed
using a git route
but the first one will be accessed under
fast id
and the second one will be accessed
using slow id
any questions the id
will represent the order in which the
request was sent
so if id1 will be sent before
id2 let's see how plumber will handle
these requests
in the receive stage the request will be
unpacked
and be prepped for processing in the
processing stage we will execute
the user function your function such as
the
fast calculation or the slow calculation
and then finally once they are done we
will bundle them up
in the response stage the receive and
respawn stage must be handled by plumber
because that is very specific
plumber logic so let's look at an
example
where we have four requests that arrive
at roughly the same time
in order it'll go a fast then a slow
and a slow and then a fast let's see how
these execute
fast comes in is processed really
quickly
responded and then done slow comes in
is received processed but
processing takes 10 seconds it is a long
time a very long time but that's okay
that's how long that route takes and
then we'll finally respond
the second slow route has been waiting
patiently but will
also take another 10 seconds to
calculate
a little long but it's okay that's how
long it takes
and then finally it will respond and the
fast route has been waiting patiently
processes really quickly and then
response to its
original request so
in total this will take
about 20 seconds the first
fast route will be processed roughly
instantly
the second request which was a slow
route
will take 10 seconds to execute and then
it will respond
but since r cannot process multiple
things at once slow 3 will have to wait
10 seconds before it can be processed
and finally fast 4 had to wait a total
of 20 seconds before it could even be
ingested in our current situation
all four requests completed in 20
seconds
however we accumulated 30 seconds of
wait time
ideally we would like this to be zero
let's explore how future can solve this
for us
so here we have our existing plumber api
code
this is what it would look like if we
incorporated it with future
future is an r package made by henrik
which allows for parallel and
distributed computing in
r let's talk about the three lines of
code that have been added
to our plumber api the first line of
code
tells future what plan should be used in
this case
we're going to use a multi-session plan
i'll leave it to you to figure out which
plan is best for your situation
the remaining code is used to tell
plumber that
hey this expression needs to be
calculated using the future r
package this allows for the main r
session to not be blocked a point of
note
must return the result of your future
call in your plumber router
for it to take effect otherwise plumber
will not know what's happening
let's take a look at the execution time
with plumber and future
with just plumber alone it took 20
seconds total
and we had 30 seconds of accumulated
wait time
however when we add in future everything
is run
immediately this allows for the total
execution time to only take 10 seconds
and we have zero accumulated wait time
this is the ideal situation and
everything is responding as fast as
possible
fast 4 responded 20 seconds earlier
and slow 3 also responded 10 seconds
earlier
this pretty good deal let's dive deep to
see how
this execution is done plumber
has the three steps that we talked about
earlier receive process
and respond this is all done on the main
r
session only one route can be there at a
time
future however can launch multiple r
sessions and we'll call them
worker one and worker two in our use
case we're only going to be using them
in the processing step
so we must receive and respond from the
main
plumber our session but we can offload
the processing
to the future workers
let's watch to see how this goes
fast comes in it is processed and we
respond
nothing new no surprise slow 2 is
offloaded immediately to worker 1.
since the main session is free then slow
3 can be offloaded to worker 2.
this allows fast forward to be processed
and respond
immediately once slow 2 is done it can
respond
same with slow 3.
that's a lot faster and a lot more going
on but
in the end we have no wait time let's
look at that again
this allows fast four since it's not
being blocked by slow 2 or slow
3 fast 4 can respond immediately
at the zero second mark and since we can
do things in parallel
slow 3 is also being processed at the
same time as slow
2. both of these do not block the main r
session
this is ideal
however there are some limitations to
what we can do with plumber in the
future
one you have to manually add your future
call wherever you deem appropriate
this is because adding the future call
adds a little bit of
execution time to each route now
if your execution time is normally in
the seconds
and adding a quarter of a second does
not mean much to you
then great i think future is a perfect
candidate for that route
however if adding a quarter of a second
to your execution time
dramatically increases it maybe adding
future is
maybe not the best idea and instead
we'll just keep it in the main r
session the other one we have to
remember is that
processing power is finite and memory is
finite
we cannot necessarily launch a hundred
thousand workers on one laptop
that would be a little bit of overload
either with processing power or the
memory
one of the two will limit what you can
do on your machine
i'd like to thank you for listening in
on how plumber and future can be
integrated to help you create an
asynchronous web api
remember offload your slow routes using
plumber expressions
and this will help keep your main
plumber worker available to process
incoming requests
thank you
[Music]
you